>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> The Library of Congress Junior
Fellows program offers undergraduate
and graduate students the
opportunity to work on projects
with specialists at
the world's largest
and most comprehensive
repository of human knowledge.
Through the Junior Fellows program,
the Library of Congress furthers
its mission to increase access
and awareness of its collections.
Junior Fellows are
exposed to a broad array
of library work including:
reference, conservation,
digitization, cataloging,
and collections processing.
Fellows work with a
broad range of materials
and use their varied
educational backgrounds to work
with the collection in
a wide array of fields.
>> BETHANY: I work on
the Yudin Collection
and the Yudin Collection
is the basis
for the Russian language collection
here at the Library of Congress.
We acquired it in 1906
and there are round
about 80,000 volumes
in this collection.
The breadth and depth
that is covered
within this collection is vast.
We have a hand written card catalog.
People who worked for
Yudin sat down and wrote
down every single book
that he ever acquired.
Neatly hand written.
It really helps us out because then
we can identify exactly what it is
and if the item that we have
is the Yudin item or not.
>> ANASTASIA: I'm working with
the Congressional Research Service
with two analysts and I'm
helping them compile a report
on behavioral health issues
among American Indians
and Alaskan natives.
I'm studying library and information
science and I have an interest
in both librarianship,
but also research
and I am particularly interested
in indigenous systems of knowledge.
And this report seemed like a
really good fit and a utilization
of both my interests and
also research on a scale
that I've never done before.
>> GRAYSON: We are working with
the popular applied graphic
arts collection.
Its scope includes pretty much
anything that was produced
for popular consumption,
commercially.
So, we have everything
from decorative prints,
chromolithographs, to
advertisements and teaching aids.
>> RYAN: This collection encompasses
hundreds and hundreds of prints.
So, in order to get through this,
we first had to organize them,
remove duplicate prints since
many of them were submitted
in pairs to the Copyright Office.
And then prepare them in an
organized fashion for the next step
which is processing them
and then recording data.
>> SARA: So, with the
recording data, we do it mostly
on a computer in an Access database.
What we do is record artist,
publisher, the medium.
And then if there are
any special notes,
we do the copyright information.
And that will be used by the
cataloger to make the record
that most patrons will see
and then it will go up online
after it's been digitized.
>> RYAN: I'm a political
science major,
so I've really been interested in
some of the drawers that have had
to do with the U.S.
government, or the military,
major sites in Washington DC.
So, it's really interesting to see
the holdings that you can find here
at the library but
not many other places
in the United States
or in the world.
>> CAROL: My responsibility is
to help digitize the Hebraic
section's manuscript collections.
So, we have approximately 225
manuscripts that we like to digitize
and make accessible to both
researchers and to the public.
And so what I've been
ding on a daily basis,
is I've been scanning
manuscripts one at a time
and making them basically uploadable
on to the Hebraic section website.
This manuscript is called a
khetuba and it's made on vellum.
So a khetuba is an official
marriage contract written
in Hebrew and Aramaic.
All of these manuscripts as
well as the khetuba are all part
of Jewish marriage ceremony in
Italy during the early modern period
into the nineteenth century.
And I just really love
seeing what's on every page
and just all the intricate details.
And so, it's been such a privilege
working to be able to work
with sometimes objects that
are 200, 300, 500 years old.
>> KATHERINE: I'm working
on a project
that involves cataloging
photographic
and photographic related
samples and photography manuals
from the nineteenth
and twentieth century.
So, what I've been doing
is to locate these samples,
to identify then in a
database, to photograph them,
and to also find other materials
in these texts about the samples.
Some of these things
we kind of found
and discovered just pulling books
off the shelf in the general stacks
and it's so amazing,
what is back there.
You don't know what you're going to
find when you open up these things.
It's totally mind-blowing.
Really, I think that's the
only way to describe it.
So, get out there and explore
in the areas you are interested
in you will find rally, in many
cases totally unique objects
that you can't find anywhere else.
>> Aside from their
assigned projects,
Junior Fellows also have a calendar
of educational enrichment activities
throughout the ten week program.
Some of these include meeting
the Acting Librarian of Congress
and tours of the National
Audio-Visual Conservation Center
in Culpeper, Virginia.
>> RYAN: Those are
really interesting places
because not even very many
Library of Congress employees,
unless you work there,
not many get to tour.
So, it was really neat to see
inside the satellite facilities
that are off limits to the public.
>> The Junior Fellows program
concludes with Display Day:
an opportunity for Fellows
to showcase their discoveries
and accomplishments and answer
questions from the Librarian
of Congress and library
staff, friends and family,
and special guests
including members of Congress.
>> BETHANY: I have loved
this program so much.
I don't think I could
have made a better choice
for my Summer internship.
I have done enough research
within this collection
that I am writing two articles to
hopefully be published with the help
of some of my supervisors.
>> KATHERINE: One of
the great things
about doing this project is working
with really wonderful conservators,
especially my supervisor whose
been a really wonderful mentor
to me here - has helped me
gain a much better knowledge
of the chemistry and technical
aspects of the production of photos,
especially in the 19th century.
And that's been really helpful.
>> RYAN: When I hear the
word, library, I thing books.
But, the Library has a
lot more than just books.
So, it's really interesting to
see the variety that go outside
of what you might initially think
of when you hear the word, library.
>> SARA: You can walk up to
anybody and ask what they're doing
and they'll explain it to you or at
least tell you what they're doing
on a basic level and I really like
that as somebody that's coming
up in that kind of field.
>> BETHANY: I would apply.
You can't do a better internship
for your library program,
for your humanities program.
This is the Library of Congress.
It's the largest library
in the world.
How can you say no?
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.